Let's go back to Oliver at this point.
He has another interview question for
us that may help make this image creation process a bit easier.
>> So one of the pain points of building an app is often that you
have to handle having 1x images, 2x and 3x, and it's a real pain.
So how can you make it easier on yourself by using vector images?
>> All right, I want you to think about this question for a bit.
There are some links in
the instructor notes that will help you get to the answer.
Here is your question one more time.
Share what you've learned with us on the discussion forum.
Check this box after you've read or submitted your response on the forum.